-So you are doing your show
in Manhattan.
-Yes.
-But I heard word
that you are operating
out of a hotel.
-We are, yes.
The Pennsylvania Hotel.
-The Pennsylvania Hotel.
The historic Pennsylvania Hotel.
-Oh, yes. Right by Penn Station.
-Yeah.
-The sexiest part of
New York City.
If you know anything about
New York City,
you know you go to Penn Station,
you get a slice of pizza,
you see some TV,
and you sleep in the bedbox.
-Yeah.
-It´s, uh, we...
-Most people walk out
of Penn Station, they say,
"I want a hotel right here!"
[ Laughter ]
-"I never want to leave!
Is there a place for
political satire around here?"
Yeah, we actually --
We toured the hotel.
They reconfigured the ballroom
to make it a studio.
And we walked around,
and it had this funny smell.
It´s like, "What is that smell?"
They´re like,
"Oh, there was a food show
in here before here."
I was like,
"Yeah, what food show?"
"The Worst Cooks"
was in here beforehand.
So you -- you could imagine
the smell.
Like, a food show beforehand
is going to smell.
"The Worst Cooks" still lives
in our studio.
-Yeah. So you have to
overcome that.
-Yes.
-But you have a great team.
You have some
"Daily Show" experience.
-Yeah.
-On this show,
you are playing a character
who is alt-right,
sort of inspired by Alex Jones,
a bit of a conspiracy theorist.
Tell us a little bit more
about the character.
-Yeah. We´re kind of diving into
this alt media landscape,
the world of "InfoWars"
and "Breitbart," "The Blaze."
Like, we found, like, this world
of, like, paranoid conspiracy
that suddenly filters its way
down into the mainstream
and into the Oval Office.
That was kind of the world
we wanted to live in.
-Yeah, it was a good time
for this.
-Yeah.
-You -- I want to talk about it,
because it´s sort of inspired
by Alex Jones.
And first I want to show,
here´s a promo for your show,
"The Opposition."
-Who are they? The enemy.
Who´s the enemy? They are.
I already said that.
Pay attention.
It´s time for us
to fight back against them,
because them are fighting
against we.
-All right, very good.
[ Laughter ]
Made it super clear.
-Very clear.
-But then -- this seems to me
like a gift.
Tell me if I´m wrong.
Alex Jones saw that promo
and did a long piece on it
on his show, on his radio show.
-He has a lot of content
to fill up on the radio show.
When you -- when you do
alt media radio,
you´re on air about 20 hours.
So if there´s something to
talk about, you talk about it.
-And here´s what he had to say
about that promo you just saw.
-He´s up there saying,
"You gotta go through me."
And then he´ll explain how
he politically operates.
He´s really telling them
how to operate,
not the way we operate.
Then he also says it
very disingenuously.
So they´re there
getting their programming
on how to attack us,
while they´re learning
to hate us,
but really they´re discovering
their identity.
This is mind control.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So here you are,
not even an episode
into your show,
and you have full engagement
with your inspiration.
It´s a great start.
-Locked and loaded.
And he is right.
It is mind control.
-Yeah, okay, good.
-Oh, yeah.
Viacom told me, "We need to get
inside the minds
of 18 to 23-year-olds,
get them engaged in the show
so we can sell them fizzy drinks
during the advertisement."
And he knows it. He sees it.
-Fantastic.
-Yes, yes, boom.
Huh, huh, huh!
Yeah, he -- he knows what
he´s doing.
He´s signaling me, he knows.
He wants me to bring it on,
and you know what? I´m happy.
-There you go.
-Yeah, uh-huh.
-And now you´ve --
But genuinely,
you have been engaging a lot,
or I should say not engaging,
but doing a lot of research
about this world
that you want to talk about.
And what is it -- You must have
uncovered some things,
some actual, genuine ways that
people interact or are drawn to
the kind of media
that you´re talking about.
-Well, I do think
when you get on the fringe
with a lot of these
media sources,
or just news in general,
I think what we´re starting
to respond to is how it´s not
necessarily the facts
that these people are
pulling from.
The veracity and validity
that they get
is how they experience
the facts.
So, like, even Alex Jones
does this on his show.
Other people as well.
It´s not about like,
"I heard this fact."
It´s like, "I experienced this.
I got this e-mail.
I saw this thing."
So an anecdote
suddenly becomes a fact
and it becomes a conspiracy
and it becomes,
through a little bit
of paranoia,
then becomes something that
other people begin to follow.
And so you just start to see
this path towards chaos.
And then you make a show
about it.
-Yeah. In making the show
about it, does it become --
Is it any less chaotic to you?
Do you sort of feel like you´re
getting your head around it?
Or in your research,
do you have a sense of,
"Oh, this is worse than
I thought?"
-I think you start to wrap
your head around it.
I mean, I would guess -- Like,
it´s cathartic to come to work
and have a bunch of writers
and be like,
"Did you see this thing?
Are you experiencing --"
And, like, to be able
to hash that out
and try to make sense of it
through a show later in the day,
I think is something that
we all gain something from.
-Yes, you will learn,
once you start doing the show,
that the off weeks are
the hard weeks
´cause that´s when you will
go crazy.
-Yes, yeah.
-Exactly.
´Cause then the news happens,
and you have nowhere to talk
about it, so you just
sort of wander around Manhattan,
talking out loud.
-And just start screaming.
That´s when I celebrate
my anniversary with my wife.
-Yeah, there you go.
-Yes. Yes.
-You came from Chicago.
Much like me,
you were an improviser.
-Yes. Mm-hmm.
-Do you have any memories of
your favorite times in Chicago,
your favorite shows?
-Favorite shows?
Probably my favorite improv show
in Chicago,
I was in a group called
"American Dream",
which was a lovely group
of people.
And we did a bunch
of weird, crazy shows.
And the one that stands out is,
one of our members
showed up late --
´cause every improviser
works two different jobs --
was exhausted
and needed to sleep.
So we did an entire show
at I.O.,
where he went to sleep on stage.
And we decided just to whisper
the entire show.
We asked the audience
not to laugh,
but to raise their hands.
[ Laughter ]
And they did.
And so we did this entire show
where people were,
instead of laughing,
were raising their hands.
And you started to see --
There was an improviser
that came in halfway through,
and just saw a bunch of people
raising their hands
and us whispering.
It was like,
"This feels like a cult."
And it was an improv show,
so he was right.
-Yeah, he was right.
Well, you´ve come a long way
from that.
And congratulations.
I really can´t wait for Monday.
Thanks so much
for being here, Jordan.
-Thank you sir. I appreciate it.
-Jordan Klepper, everybody.